i literally always have pho broth in my
freezer and i'll just sit there and
drink it out of a mug
hi my name is susan i'm a recipe
developer and i'm going to show you how
to make vietnamese fur
[Applause]
sofa is a traditional vietnamese style
noodle soup it's just the name for
actually the noodles pho means rice
noodles one of the most important
aspects of the soup is the stock to make
a really good stock you have to start
with good bones we're going to do
something called blanching your bones it
helps to take out a lot of the
impurities that you end up skimming
later my parents were both born in
vietnam and i was born here in america
and when we came here my dad was all
about becoming americans but my mom
would still cook us vietnamese food
because she felt it was important for us
to always know from our culture she
would always make these big feasts that
would revolve around something like a
fur just a big pot that goes up at the
beginning of the day then we would have
my cousins over our neighbors when my
mother first took me to vietnam and
living in america we always had fun at
lunch or dinner i remember waking up in
the morning my mom was like let's go to
breakfast and i'm sitting in ho chi minh
city nearly on the ground as like an 11
year old child eating pho first thing in
the morning it's the hottest most
delicious thing i've ever eaten and i
remember we never knew the name of the
person that made this bowl of pho we
literally just called her the old noodle
lady and my sister and i still talk
about it like to this day like do you
remember those old lady needles because
they were so good my parents had a store
in downtown seattle and right next door
to it there was a place called a little
bit of saigon i was always super bored
at my parents store so i would go next
door to the restaurant and i became
friends with one of the servers and she
kind of let me make the desserts
sometimes or make drinks and deliver
them to tables that was my playground my
mother ended up going back to vietnam
when i was in third grade so when i
wanted to have a little piece of home
i would have to learn how to cook for
myself i love making food at home
because i think that making soups of any
kind especially ones are a little bit
labor intensive it's as good as you want
to make it i take all these extra steps
to make sure at the end of eight hours
it's worth all that effort i really love
that i can have some for now and then
i'll have some for later i literally
always have pho broth in my freezer when
i moved from seattle which had a really
large vietnamese population i go next
door to a little bit of saigon and have
the best bowl of flavor when i came to
new york not quite as large of a
population of vietnamese i actually
started cooking it more when i moved to
new york because i was like if i want a
good bowl of i gotta cook it for myself
in the vietnamese culture we place a ton
of importance on food and how it can
bring people together i remember being
younger in seattle thinking that i was a
little weird because i went to a school
and most of my friends had like peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches and like my
mom didn't know what peanut butter and
jelly was so she would just pack me a
bun me and i thought it was like the
most delicious thing ever and my
friend's like what the heck is pate and
i'd be like it's so good now 2018
bunnies are sold on every corner it's
really amazing to me how far vietnamese
cuisine has come and i really love that
it's getting a little bit more
recognition it's really cool to see
other cultures come to appreciate it and
honestly makes it a little bit easier
for me to find good food that reminds me
of home food is memories and it's
important and i can have a bun me and a
fa and it brings me back to like eating
fun at stoop on ho chi minh city
i just want to eat the broth the noodles
are delicious but i just want to sip the
broth all day
you